is Russ on the album
not not right now but I'm trying to find
a song for him we were speaking about
that the other day I'm trying to find
like the perfect song Because I Love
Russ he's like one of the most
knowledgeable and talented people and
he's like a like he's like really tell
he I think he yesterday he was teasing
he's gonna put out like a 70s rock song
and I was like bro I bet it's gonna be
fire because he can do everything
he's a beast for sure you've done some
huge festivals like I feel like you've
done them all at this point but like
what was the one Festival you did where
you just looked at the crowd you were
like [__] this is [__] crazy the
biggest one ever yeah or just like or
maybe a nervous moment or just like a
like something that just sticks out the
biggest uh out to this day the biggest
Festival I've ever done was the Telethon
and Chile with J Balvin wow it was 75
000 people it was so many people that I
couldn't even see
like physical people all I could see was
little dots like little heads little
flashes of Lights crazy but that was the
most I've ever seen um most people ever
but but I love just like Festival crowds
because people that go to festivals like
they're going there they won't have to
rage yes yes so that's my favorite my
favorite energy because there's like and
then you go to a nightclub and it's like
there's people in there just like
they're holding their bottles standing
in the [__] booth and they're just
like looking at you like don't get me
wrong I love nightclubs too no no
they're great like I turn the nightclubs
up I just opened a nightclub so yes
I come pop in yeah we can booking with
Scottsdale I love Arizona too yeah it
gets wild in Scottsdale it does it does
get wild you don't know it gets wild so
you go there and see it for yourself
this is true this is true for you uh
what about going out on tour for your
fans like going and kind of just
touching your direct fan base with a
tour is that something that's coming
with this album yes yes I'm so glad you
asked that because I've never been on my
own tour I didn't say I feel like it
hasn't happened because I'm sure because
of the pandemic never and I'm such like
an like he's like an older OG artist and
I have gone on my own tour but I've
always been on tour with like huge acts
so I feel like it takes up when you go
on tour it takes up months yeah so like
you'll go on tour and you get off tour
you start recording you go on tour again
um and I think that that's just helps me
anyways because when it comes time that
I go on tour there's going to be like so
many more people for me to see and it's
like they're there for you yeah I can't
wait to see what my tour looks like like
with my fans singing album Cuts you got
the merch booming you know what I'm
saying I'm excited for that so album
coming soon really soon very soon very
very soon yeah I don't like to talk
about it I like to be about it you know
so one day we'll just be like oh the B
album's coming out in two weeks yeah
uh the new record is crazy with
Timberland thank you
um
is there a new single coming yeah
um you know me it's always a new single
coming actually now I've been way more
consistent because like I've been
learning to find that balance like when
you doing so many shows I feel like this
is like new territory for me like I've
the past two years I've been the busiest
I've ever been in my life so I've been
trying to balance like you know
new shows new music seeing family having
a social life all those things is so
hard to do I wonder like when because
I've I've seen artists who will do all
these festivals right and like
they're not doing the the shows we just
talked about like when you do your own
tour does that ever affect the way you
create like have you ever like been like
damn I gotta make a [__] Festival
record because I see a lot of guys doing
that [__] like and sometimes it can it
can kind of work out in the negative
because I think when you try to do stuff
on purpose sometimes it comes across
that way
um yeah you know well I do so many
festivals and so many like it's like
like just
shows with high energy so a lot of my
records when I go to the studio are high
energy records because I'm always
picturing myself performing records on
stage but I do have those album Cuts
Like motionless where it's like wait on
16 that's like way more vulnerable where
like I try to you know
talk my [__] but still
still give a Vibe you know
um for me it's like I like to get into
so many different beats like whatever
the beat calls for is what I'm gonna
give
what is uh bia's go-to show to binge
watch right now